das hier ist mein 123 Mürbeteig oder
auch 123 Plätzchenteig denn damit könnt
ihr wirklich alle möglichen Plätzchen
zubereiten besteht aus einem Teil Zucker
zwei Teilen Butter und drei Teilen Mehl
ich zeige euch jetzt mal einfach ein
paar Wahnsinn Daunen der ist einfach
perfekt der klebt nicht lässt sich super
verarbeiten und es wirklich schnell
hergestellt
ganz ganz wenig Mehl darunter und etwas
nehmt dann am besten einen Silikon aus
Holzstab mit Abstand bringen dann werden
die Plätzchen gleichmäßig
hier immer mit einer Palette einfach
kurz drunter gehen
und den Teig gleichmäßig ausräumen
[Musik]